it's a big night at the White House
Gwen Stefani is in Washington DC for her
performance at Tuesday night's Italy
state dinner the rocker brought her sons
Kingston Zuma and Apollo along for the
event the foursome even got to meet
President Barack Obama and first lady
Michelle it was amazing
Italian Prime Minister Matteo Renzi took
to Facebook to post this pic of everyone
together ahead of the dinner on Tuesday
Gwen and her boys were dressed to
impress rockin navy blue blazers jeans
and white button-down shirts while their
mama wore a black and white knee-length
dress with thigh high boots and tights
the first lady looked equally chic in a
black and white zigzag dress and pumps
but she stunned later in the evening as
she arrived to she and Barack's 14th and
final official state visit and state
dinner Tuesday night in this
floor-length off-the-shoulder rose gold
gown with ruching at the waist
the president looked at dapper as ever
in a tux and bowtie Wednes bow blake
shelton joined her for the presidential
dinner and the two turned heads blake
was dressed to the nines in an
impressive all-black suit shirt and tie
he paired with an American flag pin
while his ladylove dazzles in this black
and white see-through gown with a
gorgeous plunging neckline and get this
the couple performed their romantic duet
go ahead and break my heart for the
President and his guests
you